breaking down the walls people it's
great it's about damn time
once a movie has been written rewritten
by another writer shot edited re-edited
after studio notes notes color corrected
and mixed there is one last piece of
technology that has the ability to make
or break the film success no.not Twitter
the projector when that audience sits in
a darkened theater the filmmakers vision
is finally on display with the ever
increasing demands for the best looking
image Texas Instruments DLP technology
has become a world leader in digital
projection striving for the best
audience experience whilst being true to
the artists intent I feel so stupid I
thought they only made calculators ciat
- they really just never stopped working
it's great the DLP technology uses over
2 million digital micro mirrors that are
so tiny each pixel is one-fifth the
width of a human hair the projectors can
light up a movie screen a hundred feet
in size with over a hundred and
seventeen thousand projectors being used
worldwide whether it's an IMAX 2d 3d 2k
or 4k most likely you're watching it on
a DLP cinema system exciting it is this
technology has impacted so many areas of
digital projection
tonight we honor nine individuals for
their work first - Harold Milligan
Stephen Crouch oh and Reiner Dwight's
Keys the Academy presents a technical
achievement award for the development of
the Texas Instruments DLP cinema please
come on boys
good evening on behalf of Harold
Milligan Steve Cry Joe and myself we'd
like to thank the Academy Board of
Governors and members of the Academy for
this honor although we're based out of
Dallas the DLP cinema team has always
considered Hollywood our home away from
home we are very grateful for the warm
acceptance we've received from the
Hollywood industry as we work together
to get our DLP image technology adopted
so we'd like to thank the studios
post-production facilities creative
community standards community exhibitors
in our industry partners that have all
supported us to make this adoption a
reality we'd also like to thank Texas
Instruments which considers innovation
the very lifeblood of the company
although only a few of us have been
singled out for this recognition we
would have it would not have been would
not have happened without the tremendous
efforts of many on the DLP team thanks
again to the Academy for this honor last
but certainly not least we'd like to
thank our families and our wives Jill
and Karen who supported us through this
amazing journey thank you